what in heaven's name are you doing
watching youtube videos right now get
out there and buy an rtx 3070 now
it's okay i'll wait
all right
now that you've secured your place in
the queue in hopes of receiving a card
before the end of this ridiculous year
let's find out if you're going to be
keeping it
or if you're going to be scalping it on
ebay for twice what you paid
i never scalped my segways though bridge
wallet wants to redefine the wallet with
its compact frame and rfid blocking
plates keep your wallet bulge down by
using offer code linus to save 10
and get free worldwide shipping at the
link below
[Music]
clearly nvidia has had issues keeping up
with demand for their 3000 series
graphics cards and while they claim that
they pushed back the launch of today's
rtx 3070 to shore up supply given that
this is positioned as an rtx 2080 ti
killer for 500 bucks us i doubt anything
they've done in the last couple of weeks
is gonna help unless of course we fire
it up on our trusty test bench and it
falls way short of expectations
although
spoiler alert we did already tell you to
buy one it looks like as far as nvidia's
big gaming performance claims go the rtx
3070 does just fine matching or beating
our 2080 ti founders edition more often
than not at least in games that take
advantage of its beefier rt course and
tensor cores which are focused on
real-time ray tracing and deep learning
workloads respectively now there was a
time in the past when we might have
called nvidia's dlss deep learning
upscaling a
performance hack and forced their cards
to compete with it disabled but
there's just no other way to put this
it's gotten really good when we turned
all that stuff off in wolfenstein
youngblood though and forced a more
traditional rendering approach we did
observe a small but measurable four to
five percent dip in performance so
it isn't quite a 2080 ti
but at less than half the price i don't
think anyone's complaining microsoft
flight simulator while cpu bound at
virtually any resolution revealed a
curious twist in our story though the
minimum frame rate is lower than the
2080 ti but the average is higher
suggesting that while the gpu is fast
enough to keep up there's a memory
bandwidth bottleneck in the mix thanks
to the 3070's narrower 256 bit bus it
still excels in our parallel nintendo 64
test but counter-strike global offensive
sees it fall below the rtx 2080 ti again
although
we're still talking 450 versus 470
frames per second so
it's pretty easy to forgive when you
look at the bigger picture productivity
is another area where nvidia's new
ampere architecture gpus really shine
our blender renders on the 3070 went
roughly 20 to 30 percent faster than the
2080 ti that is a significant
improvement likely down to the sheer
number of cuda cores that nvidia has
packed into this thing with samsung's
eight nanometer process v-ray and
redshift show us similar results while
octane bench shows us once again the
difference between having rtx on versus
off those rt cores are where this gpu's
main advantage comes into play whenever
memory bandwidth is an issue speaking of
which the new spec vue perf 2020 shows
us that while it's great for rendering
and nearly as good for some other tasks
that just need to crunch numbers
a lot of high-end workstation users
suffer from the constrained memory
bandwidth of consumer cards like this
one and performance of our rtx 3070 fell
to as low as 80 percent of what the last
gen rtx 2080 could provide
to be fair to nvidia though that's not
what this card is designed to do it just
happens to be a consideration if you're
self-employed or working from home and
you do need to run these applications
during work hours if we average all of
our results though we can see that we're
hovering right around that magic 100
mark compared to the 2080 ti which is
extremely impressive unless the 3070 has
an achilles heel that we haven't found
yet
let's take a closer look then at our
founders edition card it's kind of
adorable isn't it
it's got the same flow-through cooler
design as the rtx 3080 and rtx 3090 but
it's super tiny and has the same fan
layout as the rtx 20 series which isn't
to say it's light i was surprised at how
heavy it is for its size and i was
surprised to see nvidia's new radical
12-pin power connector in the same
visually jarring position i mean at
least the adapter only requires a single
eight pin instead of two
which
wait why the heck wouldn't they just use
a single eight pen then it's the same
physical size like they could just
ah interestingly the grille on the i o
plate is indented a little so it bolts
directly onto the cooler rather than
tabs on the display outputs making the
design feel
much sturdier and therefore more likely
to survive a drop
cool joke anthony
just like the water in this bottle is
cool
it almost hit the mic ltt store
store.com but is the 3070 founders
edition cool
yeah it's all right
our card was able to ramp to 1.9 to 2
gigahertz all day long with its core
sitting at rtx 2080 ti temperatures
which is toastier than our rtx 2070
super but in fairness the cooler here is
significantly smaller which shows just
how efficient nvidia's pass-through
approaches when we look at power
consumption it was a touch higher over
the course of our spec view perf run
compared with the rtx 2070 super with
our peak recorded wattage no higher than
253 watts compared to that card's 224.
this is excellent news because the rtx
3080 guzzled far more power than even
the 2080 ti and the rtx 3090 sees
massive power spikes that can cause mere
mortal power supplies to just blink off
thanks to their overcurrent protection
on that subject you'll have to forgive
me for going back to the previous 3000
series launches again here but there was
yet another power debacle where some
partner boards would crash due to a
flawed power delivery design
some brands ended up shipping bad boards
all the way to customers but even ones
who didn't like evga suffered product
delays from not having all the testing
and info that they needed in time for
launch now nobody would go on the record
for us blaming nvidia for this outright
but as far as we can put together team
green just didn't give their partners
enough lead time to flesh out their
designs while they themselves enjoyed a
massive head start putting together
revolutionary new coolers for their
ampere cards now i've given nvidia the
benefit of the doubt on this so far but
with today's move it's clear that they
are openly and unashamedly competing on
an uneven playing field against their
own partners
what have they done today you might ask
well look around
where are all the reviews of
non-founders rtx 3070s that have normal
power connectors on them not in any
nvidia sanctioned reviews at the embargo
lift
why
well because their embargo hasn't lifted
yet it's kind of genius really nvidia
goes and creates a big splash and sells
out of their founders edition cards
first which they've had longer to
perfect then their partners rush to
launch their competing products with
less time to prepare giving nvidia a
second wave of review coverage comparing
their product the gpu itself with
their product the founders edition card
often quite favorably now i doubt that
anything that i say is gonna change in
videos behavior because this guy clearly
gives zero at this point
but
it's a crappy way to treat a partner and
i wanted to make sure that at least they
feel bad about it on the subject of
competition though amd's radeon
announcement is tomorrow which again
knowing nvidia is probably why they
carpet bombed the review cycle so cut
through all that noise by getting
subscribed so you don't miss our
coverage but that's not today
that's tomorrow so today from numbers
alone
it was always going to be easy to
recommend the rtx 3070 to anyone in this
price range that is assuming that you
got one before you finished watching the
intro because chances are they're all
gone by now unless you want to pay
scalper prices on ebay the good news for
the entire industry though is that
nvidia's supply woes could be amd's big
chance to make a splash with the
unveiling of their new radeon 6000
series we still don't know for sure what
that's going to look like but what we do
know is that between it
3070s compelling value and the potential
for deals on last gen cards come black
friday
it is going to be a good season to buy a
gaming rig
oh yeah and the consoles too
they're good value too like dang
it's pretty sick to be a gamer these
days just like it's pretty sick to
segue to our sponsors like the msi meg
b550 tomahawk motherboard it's got an
am4 socket with support for third gen
ryzen processors and future amd ryzen
processors with a bios update it
supports ddr4 memory up to 5100
megahertz it's got pci express gen 4 so
it is ready for your pci express gen 4
graphics cards and ssds and features a
premium thermal solution two and a half
gig on board lan and great looks check
it out today at the link in the video
description thanks for watching guys if
you enjoyed this video why not check out
our previous review of the rtx 3080 to
see why we really
really like these cards
if only they were available to buy